get 12 weeks of the spectator
in print and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
the podcast where a few writers each
week from the magazine
read out their articles this week we
hear from douglas murray and he asks
why anyone would want to be a government
advisor in light of what's happened to
tony abbott
and then we hear from historian francis
pike about
thailand's modern caligula and at the
very end
phillip henshaw reads out his review of
alex ross's new book about
wagner first douglas murray
poor tony abbott it would seem
being prime minister of australia
doesn't bring you to the attention of
the british media
to come into its sights you must be put
forward for a role as uk
trade advisor then they will discover
your existence
and aim to destroy whatever reputation
they didn't know you had
with the usual modern british charge
sheet
this time the charge was led by k burley
the latest advertisements for her sky
television show
boasts that burley is always formidable
rigorous fair honest and
searching among much else
perhaps burly hadn't seen the advert
certainly she displayed no such
qualities when she discovered the
existence of tony abbott
she immediately asserted didn't prove
just asserted that abbott is a homophobe
a misogynist a climate change denier
and wishes to kill the elderly
she then spent the next couple of days
pursuing this line of attack
in a fair and honest manner obviously
until abbott's appointment was confirmed
late last friday evening
by that stage the rest of the anti-tory
media had joined the game
pressure on pm to drop misogynist
trade advisor said the front page of one
left-wing paper
a day later the appointment having been
confirmed
the same paper ran the headline pm
appoints
misogynist abbott as trade advisor
if i were an averagely incurious young
person
this is the sort of thing that would
worry me
the uk government knowingly promotes
women haters
who are these monsters
but more exercising than the behavior of
parts of the media
was the now traditional limpness of the
conservative ministers put up to defend
their proposed appointment
first up was matt hancock and even the
nhs badge pinned to his lapel could not
ward off the evil spell words burly
threw at him about abbott
while burley did the full homophobic
misogynist killer of polar bears and the
elderly shtick
hancock managed just about to splutter
something about abbott knowing about
trade
he almost said notwithstanding
a day later the equally wet grant shaps
had the same smear sheet recited at him
by burley
he too seemed incapable of finding any
words to defend the former australian
prime minister
with that extraordinary brilliance one
tends to associate with shaps
he pointed out that abbott had not yet
been appointed
he then filled up some time talking
about modern society
conversations and respect by which he
did not of course
mean respect for anyone who might still
be a catholic
would shapes agree to have a drink with
a man of abbott's views
asked burley rigorously she
firmly and indeed formidably stated that
she
would not for a moment shaps
seemed to be weighing up the issue as
though
drinks with chaps are a widely
recognized honor
almost as much as having a drink with k
burley
when people wonder why there are so few
conservatives in public life
these are the occasions they should
reflect on
for not all people put forward for such
positions have the distinction of being
a former prime minister
of a close ally anyone now put forward
must be aware that however minor the
role it will entail their being accused
without any evidence
of all the same sins of which abbot was
accused
and instead of being given a robust
defense by your own side when the left
attacks
you will find hancock shaps or james
brokenshire if you're lucky
defending your whole life work and
character
so while there may be some tory
rejoicing when one of their appointments
is squeezed through
all the time the desire of sane people
of the right to enter public life
diminishes even further
personally i find that these episodes
bring out my vengeful
streak a streak which is otherwise
carefully hidden
after watching the treatment of tony
abbott i
started dreaming of scorched earth
strategies
if the left are so intent on hurling the
same boring accusations
and the writer going to remain so cowed
then
why not give them some of the strong
stuff and be done with it
put taki in charge of reforming the bbc
or make him the next head of the
equality and human rights commission
push him through let them squeal and
everyone else afterwards might be
treated with a shade more understanding
as it happens another ally of this
country has answered part of the problem
in a slightly more practical way last
week president trump announced that from
now on
all those divisive white privileged
training sessions for government staff
will be stopped they are the
administration correctly said
propaganda the british government
would do well to follow this currently
in order to get any public position or
to work for the civil service
you must jump through a whole course of
entirely left
invented hoops these include things like
having to prove your commitment to
diversity
if you are white or male let alone
white male and heterosexual this is a
tough call
and so people boast about their
commitment to left-wing causes
and swear fealty to left-created ideas
by now this has had an effect
of course not all tories are as wet as
hancock and chaps
but it is aggravating to hear the
occasional right-wing tory
burst out about the left-wingery of
universities
or the wokeness of the bbc while these
same ministers preside over public
appointments bodies
and a civil service absolutely packed
with implicit bias training
and the whole rest of the croc divisive
social justice agenda
the same might be said of the police as
well
if the conservatives cannot put up
someone like tony abbott for a position
without him being fired at in the manner
in which he was
then it is time to change the game
the way to do so is not just to drop the
whole
falsely termed social justice agenda
but to strip it out of the heart of
government
like the mental and moral asbestos
that it is that was douglas murray
and now the historian francis pike get
12 weeks of the spectator
in print and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher the roman emperor
caligula
was renowned for his extravagance
capricious cruelty
sexual deviancy and temper balling on
insanity
most famously before he was assassinated
he planned to appoint his favorite horse
as a consul
this is probably a legend but king maha
vajiralongkorn who ascended the throne
in thailand in 2016 adopted caligula's
playbook for real
in 2009 the then crown prince promoted
his pet minisha poodle
fufu to the post of air chief marshall
in which capacity he served until his
death in 2015
aged 17. fufu's cremation
was preceded by four days of formal
buddhist mourning
the poodle first came to the attention
of the general public
when the video was released showing him
eating cake
from the hand of vajra longhorn's third
wife
princess ciarasmi while she converted in
a g-string in the dog's
lavish birthday party at a 2009
gala dinner in honor of vajrayo longhorn
fufu was kitted out head to paw in black
thai dress
and according to a wikileaks revealed
account by u.s ambassador ralph boyce
jumped onto the head table and began
lapping from the guests water glasses
including my own when on parade
the new king wears crisp snowy white
gold braided
roritanian military uniforms or
elaborate
thai regalia that make him look like a
buddhist temple in human form
in downtime his dress can best be
described
as kinky trainers and low hung jeans
paired with the skimpiest of crop tops
his back and arms are festooned with
possibly
fake tattoos roger longhorn is famous
electricity
indeed in his youth thai aristocrats
would pack off their daughters to europe
to get them out of his clutches
happily for bangkok's elite the crown
prince's tastes
after his divorce from his first wife an
aristocratic relative of his mother
were consistently low rent his second
wife
was an aspiring actress albeit of the
soft porn variety
the marriage did not last art of vajraya
longhorn put posters all over the palace
accusing her of adultery
she fled to london and later to the u.s
with her children
apart from a daughter who was kidnapped
and brought back to bangkok
the daughter was elevated to the rank of
princess but her mother
and brothers had their diplomatic
passports and royal titles
revoked by the crown prince the thai
public was left horrified by his
treatment of his family
another marriage followed in 2001
to the aforementioned cerasmi though is
not publicly announced
until 2005 when the crown prince
by then in his early 50s declared that
it was time to settle down
however in 2014 he stripped his wife
of her royal titles because of her
relative's corruption
sirasmi's parents were jailed for two
and a half years each
for they say majesty
five years later on the first of may
last year
and just three days before his official
coronation
vajra longhorn married for the fourth
time
to sufida tidjai a former
thai airways hostess giving her the
title of queen concert
the thai people were dumbfounded when
just two months
later the new king named his mistress
major general sininat
wong vadhira padgy as his royal
noble consult it was the first time this
form of address had been used for more
than 100 years
the new relationship lasted three months
on the 21st of october cenina was
stripped of all her
titles and disappeared from public view
supposedly
for being disrespectful to the queen
the king's extravagance is no less
remarkable than his private life
a monarchy that was impoverished in the
post-war period had
by some estimates increased its wealth
to between
40 and 60 billion dollars by last year
most of the wealth resides in land
ownership of some four square miles of
central bangkok
makes the thai monarchy the world's
wealthiest by a large margin
overseas holdings include a major stake
in the kempinski hotel group
indeed for years badger alonghorn has
spent months on end
at the munich kempinski with his harem
and servants
in addition he owns a mansion
on lake starnberg to the south west of
munich
in spite of his huge allowances as crown
prince
affording him ownership of two boeing
737s
it is thought that the then prime
minister attacks in shinawatra
had to cover his gambling debts
why do king raja long-cons private
shenanigans matter
royal families throughout europe have
long weathered sexual and financial
scandals
juan carlos may have been forced to step
down as king
and go into exile but the spanish
monarchy has survived
so too has the belgian monarchy after
the former king albert ii
admitted to having a love child
there is no suggestion that prince
andrew cherubic by comparison with king
vader along kong will bring down the
british royals because of the epstein
imbroglio but the key difference is that
unlike thailand all those are
constitutional monarchies
in thailand the monarchy is integral to
the country's
real power structures this was a 70 year
legacy
of vajra longhorn's father king bhumibol
broomball's reign started under a cloud
following the killing of his 20 year old
predecessor
king ananda mahidol by a single shot to
the head with a colt 45 pistol
after a questionable trial two servants
were executed for the murder
though it is widely suspected that the
king was accidentally shot by
bhumibol his brother for the first
decade of his rule king bhumibol was
entirely powerless
and lived under the rule of the
quasi-dictator field marsha
marshall fibon songkran who
during the second world war had allied
thailand with the axis powers
but gradually as thailand inched towards
a democracy
bhumibol won the adoration of the thai
people
thanks to his moderating influence and
good works
such as paying for medical facilities
for the poor
his political power increased in 1952 he
bravely refused to preside over
ceremonies for fibon songkran's new
militaristic constitution
however boom boom's finest moment came
in 1981 when he faced down
the so-called april fool's day coup
d'etat
by fleeing bangkok and raising the thai
royal standard
at the military base at correct where
general prem
emerged as the new military strongman
they followed what is now known as the
network monarchy era
a coalition of military interests and
those of the financial and industrial
elite
based in bangkok as a former american
deputy president
at thailand's bank of asia noted
thai politics has been about dividing up
the pie among the elite
at the center of the web stood the thai
monarchy
elected democratic institutions remained
largely an adornment to this oligarchic
structure
in 2001 a business chancellor a mobile
phone billionaire
taxing shinawatra later the owner of
manchester city football club
swept to power with his tirac thai party
promising a popular agenda including
reform of health and education
much to the chagrin of the network
monarchy
taxon won a sweeping victory again in
2005.
boomiball who loathed taxin gave tacit
support to the coup
that first removed him and then sent him
into exile two years later
until his death in 2016
bhumibol thwarted either by military or
judicial coup
the democratic will of the thai people
who
since 2001 have consistently voted into
power
taxing backed parties and their proxy
leaders
boom bell's historic reputation albeit
tarnished by his thwarting of the
democratic
will became an important pillar of
resistance
to taxing's outsiders
after boom bowl's death in 2016
the critical power of the monarchy was
left in the hands
of his dissolute playboy's son
will king vader longhorn redeem his dire
youth
reputation and do a prince hal
moving to the path of royal
righteousness
the signs so far are not good just over
a week ago
the royal noble consult cenina suddenly
reemerged
with no information other than an
inventive royal gazette announcement
it will be regarded that she never was
stripped
of the royal consul title military ranks
and royal decorations more important
than this saga
of extraordinary extrajudicial fiat
the king intervened in the drafting of a
new constitution by the military junta
in 2017 to grant himself
new powers over the employment of
regents
in addition the new constitution
asserted the king's right to manage
during any constitutional crisis given
that thailand has had
17 military coups since 1932
this is not trivial two crack regiments
have also been put
under his direct control as the
political exile
and professor at kyoto university pavin
chachaval
pongpun has noted the king is basically
running the country now
though he's not doing it like his father
did through moral authority
he's using fear to solidify his position
and to take command
it is therefore interesting that in the
past month
demonstrations of up to 10 000 people
have called for the powers of the king
to be curtailed
protesters have defied thailand's
draconian
they say majesty laws which can incur
up to 15 years imprisonment
they have chanted down with feudalism
it remains to be seen whether the
protests are a straw in the wind of
future political instability
the new king's attempt to transition
from a monarch with influence
within network monarchy to moniker rules
is fraught with danger but at least
fragile longhorn is unlikely to come to
caligula's sticky end
the king has already made home for an
exile
in his beloved bavaria that was francis
pike
and now a review by philip hensham of
alex ross's wagnerism
art and politics in the shadow of music
in the early 1920s a french businessman
leon bell was looking for a name for his
new brand of processed
cheese he remembered seeing a meat wagon
on the first world war battlefields
with the sardonic name lavashkori
like the valkyries in wagner it brought
solace to fallen soldiers in the field
belle thought it would do very well and
gave his cheese
the same name in a more orthodox
spelling
re the laughing cow is still very
popular today
reading this completely unsuspected
story of a trademark in
alex ross's book i wondered with some
astonishment at this world
a businessman looking for a striking
name for a mass market product
hits on a joke about the title of a
five-hour german music drama
written 70 years earlier and it succeeds
his market actually knows what he's
talking about
wagner gripped the communal mind for
decades after his death in 1883
and he's not done with us yet ross has
written a book about vargas consequences
with one striking omission what he did
with music
and what he did to music
wagner was above all a composer
the power of his musical invention is
the reason why he is still in
our lives all other mythical dramatists
contrivers of theatrical spectacle
political theorists and grubby purveyors
of national and racial theories from his
time
have disappeared as wagner without his
music
would certainly have disappeared
nevertheless it is possible as ross has
found
to write a very long book about his
influence which has almost nothing to
say about the music itself
and which doesn't find it necessary to
talk about the music that was shaped
by him ross quotes an american
mythographer
saying that wagner's two great successes
are james joyce
and thomas mann rather than for instance
debussy
and schoenberg is an eccentric approach
but entirely possible many of the best
creative minds of the time
were immediately engaged by
many of the best creative minds of the
time were immediately engaged
by wagner's endeavor between the 1850
weimar premiere of lohan grin
and the 1865 premiere of tristanland is
older
wagner had written four full-length
operas
and two acts of another concert
performances had built up interest
across europe by the time of the
construction of the theater in byroid
solely for the performance of his work
and the first production there in 1876
of the full cycle of the ring of the
nibelong
wagner was probably the object of more
feverish intellectual speculation
than any artist in the world
one more music drama followed parsifal
expressly written for the unique byroid
design
and acoustics and confined to
performances there
until the 20th century
the division between wagner and
wagnerism was already apparent
in the composer's lifetime in many of
the best houses even today you can be
ticked off for applauding after the
first act of parsifal
rather than filing out in sacramentally
silent
ore the tradition goes back to the
original performances but it's recorded
that the audience member who was
indignantly hissed for yelling brave
the flower maidens turned out when the
lights were raised
to be wagner himself once he was dead
and control passed to his terrifying
widow kozuma
all bets were off ross does a very good
and full job in tracing the obsession of
different times and places
in the intellectual flavor each wave
took
the young george bernard shaw's take on
the ring a socialist
allegory or the mystical withdrawal into
teutonic obscurity of french poets
from baudelaire to maname and onwards
oddly ross doesn't mention the
wonderfully self-named poet
tristan clingsaw there are passages
about the cult of wagner in japan
surprisingly early children's guides to
wagner
were being published in 1928 and about
the philosophers
wagner in my view you'd be about as
likely to buy a ticket for gerta demeron
on the basis of its philosophical
content
as you would be to base your plans for
international world domination
on a round of risk but wagner
was deep in schopenhauer and nietzsche
was torn in two by his fascination with
then rejection of the composer
philosophers have continued
to gnaw at his work
as time went on wagner proved more and
more
prophetic the theater at byroid is
astonishingly reminiscent of a cinema
with its total dark invisible source of
sound
and apparently floating stage picture
filmmakers have gone on stealing from
him from direct illusion to probably
unconscious theft from what is probably
now
common mythical currency
tolkien took the idea of the ring from
wagner
it has no other source and parsifal
stilling klingsel's
throne spear in mid-air turns up at the
climax of
the matrix the question at the center
of this study of course is wagner's
responsibility for
and relationship with hitler there's no
doubt
that wagner like many 19th century
figures was personally anti-semitic in a
more than casual way
there is also the point that byroid was
very happy to be used by hitler as a
venue for one of his festivals of
teutonic culture
just as himmler turned kvedlinborg into
a center of hieratic
pilgrimage wagner's politics are complex
however
and went through a series of different
stages
in the 1920s german commentators quite
reasonably regretted that the idealistic
revolutionary spirit of equality
apparent in wagner
had been lost to a fascist faction of
admirers
the claim that there is anti-semitism in
the operas themselves
runs up in my view against some awkward
facts
first there's no evidence that opera
productions during the third reich
ever depicted the characters mima and
beckmesser as jewish
hitler never made any kind of comment on
wagner's attitude to the jews
most of the nazis detested wagner and
even denounced the compassionate
conclusion
of parcephal there is nothing in any of
the opera's music
which unarguably indicates that the
character might be jewish
though musical conventions were well
established
the vile caricature in muzorski's
pictures at an exhibition
predates the ring
ross is very conscious of the complexity
of these questions and how they have
become more complicated
with a passage of time his omission of
much consideration
of wagner's music has the curious effect
of making those who were obsessed by him
sound somewhat deranged this however
is not always inappropriate and much of
the story is inevitably of gross misuse
on both sides thomas martin wrote very
truly of
the malicious abuse to which this great
object
somewhat lends itself
that goes both for the by right
audiences in the 1930s rising to salute
hitler
in the last scenes of de meistersinger
and the conspicuously non-musical
polemicists who have since
attempted to erase wagner from concert
programs
on the unproven and implausible claim
that his music was played
daily in the concentration camps it was
more likely to have been
schubert ross's book is excellent
and extraordinarily thorough though one
occasionally misses a musically literate
person
saying something intelligent about
wagner debussy on the orchestration of
parcephal appearing illuminated from
behind
or barely is saying that the tristan
prelude was nothing but a pogiaturas
there are plenty of books about that
leaving the music to one side
ross's is a very thorough account of
apparent delusion
in search of a fugitive meaning
in the end one can only say that what
wagner created in pure sound
is of such power that it will always
survive
the worst of its creator's character and
the characters
of the worst of his admirers what it
means
was perhaps best accounted for by of all
people the novelist philip k
dick pacifal is one of those
corkscrew artifacts of culture in which
you get a subjective sense that you've
learned
something from it something valuable or
even priceless
but on closer inspection you suddenly
begin to scratch your head and say
wait a minute this makes no sense
it might be a description of all of the
greatest art
and in the end the message over which
posterity labored so
hard is secondary to darkness falling in
a room
in northern bavaria silence
from the depths the single note of a
flat
in unison from wind and strings
it starts that was philip henscher
thanks for listening to this episode of
spectator out loud
and do join us again next week
[Music]
you